hey everybody and welcome to another hd
video this is not exactly a tutorial but
it's just me showing you guys a new
website uh where you can get uh
basically any google chrome add-on you
can think of at this website you may
have already heard of this but i just
feel like showing you guys who have been
asking me where can i get google chrome
add-ons now this video before i get into
it is also a test for my new microphone
quality i'm going to be uploading a
video of the unboxing and then shortly
after i'll be uploading a review video
so if you're following me on twitter
you'll be able to see when i put out
those videos so anyway here we go uh
this is the google chrome add-ons
website the link is my
mychromeaddons.com and yes the link will
be in the description
so if we scroll down here or i'm not
going to scroll down but basically we
can see that this website is a very
extensive website where you can find um
google chrome add-ons themes plug-ins
whole bunch of stuff and there is a
little advertising on the page but you
can block that in firefox so yeah this
is really cool um you there are tags so
you can obviously search here if i go
scroll to the top this is basically it
looks like it's google chrome basically
but um if we go type in
os x and we can search that and there
are os 10 themes from mac or for google
chrome
so yeah i just want to show you guys a
quick uh overview of this website if i
go back here we can show you guys uh
they do include installation
instructions um on their website so
under each add-on depending on the type
of add-on it is it'll have a different
set of instructions for you guys to
install it so now um
yeah this is a whole lot of different
tasks and add-ons here we go here's a
google chrome
mac os 10 theme so yeah it tells you the
add-on
sorry it tells you the author it tells
you the comments on it um under it do
you need a mac of course you don't but
anyway yeah there's a whole lot of
different things you can find on this
website so again
mychromeaddons.com link link is in the
description and when i uh download and
install google chrome if anyone wants to
know i can i can make a tutorial on
actually installing these add-ons and
like you know just my top five chrome
add-ons or something just leave a
comment about what you like so yeah go
ahead and check out this website if
you're using google chrome if you like
it if you're looking to expand it like
firefox go check this out so yeah thanks
for watching this video and uh subscribe
peace